with President Ellis having now shown as
true intentions he is on the run and has
been protected by the black tusk ative
returned the United States is now
currently leaderless and while DC
crumbles around them who would almost
seem that the divisions main objective
to ensure the continuity of government
has failed but how did it get to this
point
[Music]
[Music]
you
Lawrence Waller was a President of the
United States when the green poison
outbreak began in New York City Waller
was an academically gifted student
graduating from Harvard University he
went on to become a criminal defense
lawyer before deciding to get into
politics when the green poison epidemic
struck president Waller was clearly
concerned and demanded that it be kept
up to date with how bad it was getting
in New York he immediately assumed that
this was an attack by another country
like Russia or China however he was
advised that this was unlikely due to
them having problems of their own it was
confirmed by later reports that the
green poison had spread to over a
hundred countries Waller declared
martial law and merged the police fire
department and National Guard to form
the Joint Task Force their job to set up
and control the quarantine around
central Manhattan it quickly became
obvious that this was a much bigger task
than originally thought after seeking
advice with his vice president Thomas
Mendez and the Speaker of the House
Andrew Ellis president Waller used
directive 51 and activated the strategic
homeland division the first wave agents
were dispatched at to New York City with
the orders to assist the JTF in
maintaining the quarantine in Manhattan
and protecting the thousands of
innocents inside however it didn't take
long before the president was briefed by
a JTF general he said that the small
team of division agents senton had
proved ineffective at controlling the
quarantine zone and on top of this some
of the first wave that turned against
the government and gone rogue with all
due respect mr. president you can't hold
up in a situation like this half
measures aren't worth squat half
measures my ass those agents have full
executive authority and the most
advanced tech in our arsenal
none of them matters they can chuck them
into the deep end without a lifeline
Jesus Larry you've read history books
fine call louie Chang and let him know
the second wave is ago Walla ordered the
general to contact Louis Chang to
dispatch the second wave into New York
shortly after this president Walla was
found dead he died of a heart attack
following president walls death vice
president Thomas Mendez was quickly
sworn and under the 25th amendment and
became the second president of the
dollar flu outbreak Mendez was born in
Seattle his family owned a business that
he hoped to inherit from a young age
Mendez was a statistical genius and ran
a very profitable real estate enterprise
before he transitioned into politics as
the vice president economics were his
area of expertise and the main component
in its decision-making when president
wall was considering the use of
directive 51 Mendez questioned him he
believed that this was upset the
American people and politically damaged
woola's reputation however he was
quickly overruled by Waller and Andrew
Ellis they agreed that the situation was
bad enough to warrant it are you sure
you want to do this the optics are gonna
be terrible with all due respect mr.
Mendez screw the optics is that a crisis
state and this is the one club I've got
left in my bag hell if I'm not gonna
take a swing agreed
hopefully this will only be needed for a
short time and we can deal with the
fallout once the crisis has passed and
if it's not quickly what do we do then
then you better learn some useful skills
because if this thing drags on the damn
optics will be the least of our worries
soon after Wallis death Mendez was sworn
in as president of the United States the
cities of New York and Washington DC
descended into chaos this was due to his
inability to manage the crisis Mendez
was left with no choice but to order the
remaining officials of the federal
government to evacuate the Capitol
shortly after this he called an
emergency meeting with the United
Nations unaware of how far the
devastation it spread he was briefed by
an ambassador that the green poison had
spread to every continent in the world
and that the casualties would be in the
tens of millions president Mendez is
believed to have been one of the last
officials that would have been evacuated
from DC however before this happened
his body is discovered appearing as
though he's committed suicide
given how things were going there is no
proper investigation carried out rumors
started circulating some saying that he
committed suicide due to the stress of
being president during the outbreak
others say it was because he was
infected with the virus regardless the
Speaker of the House Andrew Ellis was
quickly sworn in as president at the
undisclosed location that the government
was evacuated to later on it was found
through an echo that President Mendez is
betrayed by two members of The Secret
Service they were promised safe passage
out of the city by the black tusk if
they murdered Mendez and made it look
like a suicide
they were interned killed in an
underground parking lot to cover up the
assassination President Andrew Ellis
comes from a long line of wealthy public
servants he was educated in a private
school and spent four years at the Naval
Academy in Annapolis where he proved
himself to be a natural leader
Ellis aspires to build a brand new
America and is willing to do whatever it
takes to achieve his goals he was
considering a bid for the presidency
during the last election but decided
that the timing wasn't quite right in
the grand Washington hotel a poster on
the wall reveals a Ellis as part of a
pro private military contractor group
and was due to attend a conference with
Lieutenant Colonel Charles bliss of the
last man battalion as a guest speaker
when the outbreak first occurred L
supported president Wars decision in
activating directive 51 and around the
same time he was contacted by an
anonymous individual about a potential
opportunity I believe senator Richards
was already in contact with you
he certainly piqued my curiosity I'd be
interested to hear what exactly your
friends have in mind and how I would fit
into the equation excellent it would be
best to discuss the specifics in person
Ellis was evacuated along with the
surviving members of the federal
government while hidden away with the
rest of the federal government Ellis was
approached by the black tusk he was
briefed on the part that were used to
play and we'll sit back to Washington DC
to keep the division in line and to make
sure they didn't
I think it's risk which is why I want
you 24/7 reminding them who they work
for and watching out for telltale signs
of misguided idealism there'll be a
tremendous asset if they get in our way
they're gonna be a hell of a pain in the
ass in which case we need advance
warning so that we can take preventive
measures when do I leave Sousa Plains
done fueling am i kicking up your heels
and the Oval Office by sundown on his
way back to the capital
aboard Air Force One they were shot down
by a surface-to-air missile
those assumed that President Ellis was
killed an informant within the hyenas
provided information that they had
stolen something from Air Force One
crash site the division raided the bank
headquarters to recover what the hyenas
stole and while there they managed to
intercept a hyena transmission
revealing that President Ellis is still
alive and was being held hostage
the division quickly found him and had
him extracted via helicopter once back
in the white house prisoner Ellis called
for a meeting with many Kelso in the
player agent he stated as reasons for
returning that there were samples of a
broad spectrum antiviral medication that
will set to DC as a continuity of
government measure Ellis continued on to
talk about how the medication can cure
all viral infections like dengue fever
the common cold and even the doll flu
but in order to access the location of
where it was being held he required the
briefcase to do was carrying on board
Air Force One when it crashed the
division believed that this was likely
with the true sons in the Capitol
building
Ellis ordered them to get it back by any
means necessary after the division
re-established the shd satellite network
President Ellis gave a speech at the
White House saying that they would kick
all enemy factions out of DC soon after
this the division of the JTF launched
assaults at the district union arena
Roosevelt Island and Capitol building
after solving the final enemy stronghold
the Capitol building and defeating the
true sons they found and brought back
the briefcase to the White House however
this was the moment that the full-scale
invasion was launched into the city the
black tusks had finally revealed
themselves and the true force and it was
at this time that President Ellis
disappeared along with the briefcase
after discovering the location of the
broad spectrum antibiotic rhetoric White
House South Lawn the division observed
the anti virus had already been taken
and echo at the scene reveals that
President Ellis had been working with a
black tusk all along and had given them
the antivirals Ellis was immediately
declared a traitor and a manhunt was
started to bring him to justice after
pushing the black tusk back through a
series of battles across the city the
division launched an attack on their
base at tidal basin as though trying to
extract the antivirals but the division
managed to stop them in time and claim
the medication
it wasn't until they defeated the black
tusk at the Washington National Airport
that the division learned of president
alice's location camp white oak this is
a presidential retreat and was under
heavy guard but the black task forces
the JTF and the division mounted attack
on the compound but they were too late
prison else managed to evacuate in an
Air Force helicopter Alice's whereabouts
are once again unknown given the black
tusk history of quickly disposing of
assets once they've completed their
tasks it's obvious the Alice's still
some value to them we don't know what
they plan for Alice's at the stage but
given his position and the fact that
they're continuing to keep them safe
it's likely to be something to do with
the US public and the easing of the
transition into the new dynasty that
blackest employer has in mind he will be
the figurehead or the puppet of this
unknown group that plans to reshape the
future of the United States of America
however this may not be what Ellis has
in mind
Jesus Andrew are you sure about this you
said it yourself somebody has to step up
what do you know about these people can
you trust them I'm just a pawn as far as
they're concerned isn't that kind of a
shitty position to put yourself in the
thing is pawns are dangerous precisely
because people underestimate them you
think you can turn this to your
advantage I'm confident I can make
myself indispensable and get some things
done that have needed doing for a good
long time I don't know this is a
dangerous game to play is there any
other kind these days
thanks for watching guys I had to record
this in the garden shed the newborn
wasn't keen on cooperating it's cold out
here and I'm pretty sure I ate a couple
of bugs but hopefully this came out okay
I'll be continuing the story as more
information comes available but what do
you think is gonna happen next
what do you think the black tusks have
planned at the same time if you have any
other topics in the division universe
that you'd like me to cover let me know
in the comments below otherwise inserts
social media spill here and yep Cheers